كريستيانو رونالدو رد على
ربما التعليقات التي أدليت بها عنه
سابقاً وقال إن هذا
النقد قد يكون بدافع الغيرة
لمن ترد على وجهة النظر
هذه أو على هذا الرأي الخاص بك هل
رأيت تعليقي نعم رأيت  هي وأنا أعتقد أن
تعليقاتي كانت تمدحه
كلاعب لأن مسيرته المهنية كنت
ممتنًا جدًا لذلك في رأيي أن
جيمي ميسي أفضل لاعبين
في تاريخ اللعبة وما
قلته كان في اللحظات العمرية أيضًا.  وهو
ما يفعله بالطبع ، من الواضح أنه
أسرع قليلاً من
كريستيانو
لكنني أعتقد أنه من الغريب جدًا أن تكون
المقابلة توقيتًا غريبًا جدًا وقد اختار أن
يفعل ذلك هذا هو اختياره ، أنا متأكد من أن
مانشستر يونايتد سيبحث في
مقابلة وسيتعاملون معها
مهما قلت عندما أقول إنهم يشعرون
أنهم بحاجة إلى ذلك
، أعتقد أنني كنت مجاملة للغاية
منه ومرتبكة بعض الشيء وفي رده
هل تعتقد حقًا أنه يجب عليهم الإنهاء
العقد على الفور أو أنا متأكد
من أنني لست متأكدًا من أن مان يونايتد سيتخذ
هذا القرار
في مقابلته من
وجهة نظري ، إنه أمر غريب بالطبع ،
لا أعتقد أننا رأينا لاعبًا ذاهبًا
إلى  افعل هذا إلى هذا الحد مع العلم
بالعناوين الرئيسية التي
ستجلبها وأنا متأكد من أنهم سوف ينظرون إليها
عن كثب وأنا متأكد من أننا
سنعرف على الأرجح القرار الذي سيتوصلون إليه
قريبًا جدًا
وانتقده ثم هاج و  قال إنني
لا أحترم ، فأنا
لا أحترمه لأنه لا يحترمني ، هل
توافق على
أنني أعتقد كأي لاعب ، وأي مدرب
بالطبع ، ما تبحث عنه دائمًا هو
الاحترام في كلا الاتجاهين و  في
رأيي ، تعامل Sanhack مع الموقف برمته
جيدًا
ومن الواضح أنني لا
أعرف اسم الخلفية لذلك لا أعرف
ما الذي يحدث في الخلفية
ولكن ما زلت أعرفه هو ما
أراه وأعتقد أن عشرة هاج  هو اختيار فريقه
الذي يعتقد أنه أفضل فريق
للحصول على نتائج وكذلك من الخارج
يبدو أنه تعامل مع الأمر
بشكل جيد حقًا وبعد ذلك ، لكن بالطبع
سيكون لكريستيانو آرائه الخاصة بها